we're gonna go over this story
i'm very anti-conspiracy theory so i
hope you're all prepared for me to be
very skeptical about a lot of stuff but
we're gonna have fun with it
but i i'm gonna i'm also gonna bring up
the story from a story from 2013 about a
journalist named michael hastings
mainstream reporters okay this is a
journalist
somehow died car accident it's very very
suspect
circumstances this guy's you know uh
rest in peace i mean with all due
respect to michael hastings and his
family and everything but he was uh
according to the story worried about
someone tampering with his car
asked to borrow someone else's car
panicked and then like a day later
his car was going 70 miles an hour down
the road slammed into a tree
and some apparently experts said it
sounded like a car hack
this guy was doing some like deep
investigation and i'll tell you why
journalism is is deadness in in this
country
in many parts of the world because of
stories like the one we're about to tell
you
as i said a moment ago a fedex delivery
driver
that's who walked up to this house and
apparently you know knocked in the door
ring the doorbell
20 year old kid answers it you see a
fedex guy out the window what do you do
answer the door ball to the chest bang
that's why journalists are gone this is
a judge mind you that's why i want to
talk about michael haysing so let's just
let's let's not even let's not even mess
around we got a lot to talk about in
this story
here's the first story from the
financial times
gunman attacks house of judge over
overseeing epstein lawsuit fbi
identifies
anti-feminist lawyer as primary subject
in shooting that killed esther salas's
son
now this is another really weird aspect
of the story the dude apparently
was like a men's rights activist they
say anti-feminist but he was you know
he wasn't suing like i don't know it
sounds like he was a men's rights lawyer
okay so this is all part weird part but
let's read i'll give you the full
context
they say the fbi has identified a
self-described anti-feminist lawyer
as the primary subject in a brutal
attack against the home of a federal
judge in new jersey that killed her
20-year-old son and injured her husband
in a tweet on monday the fbi's branch in
newark new jersey
said that roy den hollander who is known
for pursuing legal claims alleging
discrimination against men
was the main target in its investigation
into the deadly sunday shooting
at the home of judge esther salas the
fbi confirmed
that dan hollander was dead after media
reports said he had been found in new
york state
last week judge salas who was not hurt
in the assault had been assigned to
oversee a lawsuit filed by investors
against deutsche bank
they alleged that the bank had made
false and misleading statements with
regards to its anti-money laundering
practices
and had improperly monitored high-risk
customers including the late
disgraced epstein authorities
have not linked the shooting to the
deutsche bank case
the fbi has not offered any motive for
the attack bill barr the u.s attorney
general on monday said
this kind of lawless evil action carried
against a member of the federal
judiciary will not be tolerated
judge salus and her family are in our
thoughts at this at this time
as they cope with this senseless act
phil murphy the governor of new jersey
wrote on twitter
according to cnn the gunman was
disguised as a fedex delivery driver
opened fire as soon as the home the door
of the home was opened
daniel andrill misalice's 20 year old
son was fatally struck
mark anderle a criminal defense attorney
was taken to the hospital near their
home in north brunswick new jersey
judge salus had dealt with den hollander
in the past
as he was pursuing a case challenging
the male only military draft in the u.s
bob menendez the democratic senator from
new jersey said he knew judge salas
and her husband well and had been proud
to recommend her to barack obama
for the judicial post which she took up
nine years ago
my prayers are with judge salas and her
family and that those responsible for
this horrendous act are swiftly
apprehended and brought to justice mr
menendez
you know the story of uh senator
menendez no i don't
do you i do i'm going to be very very
vague
very vague but there were accusations
it's my general understanding and based
on
i'm being very legally careful here
based on my
readings of the news and what i remember
of them which could be wrong it's been a
long time and i haven't pulled it up
senator menendez was accused of engaging
in adult activities with women under the
age of 18.
and i think where was it dominican
republic dominican republic you want to
look it up so we can make sure we have
this yep right now
and apparently one of the arguments from
them in their defense was
even if he did it it wouldn't be illegal
in that country
he said those words that that was like
some kind of well that was there
i could be though there was a defense
from a lawyer it is my understanding
and i could be misremembering this but
that was something that was being passed
around and i could absolutely be wrong i
don't
i i could be wrong i don't have that
pulled up i'm only bringing it up
because of uh
the associations in the story but hold
on i'm gonna put everything on pause
right now
here's a guy who is they're saying he's
an anti-feminist
i don't know if that's fair he's a men's
rights lawyer you know he's he's suing
four
men and you know to get there's a
difference between targeting feminists
and supporting men i guess the media
doesn't make that distinction or
whatever
it's entirely possible this has nothing
to do with epstein and the only reason
this is coming up
is because someone noticed she just
received this case
and are trying to connect it because
it's a salacious story
let's make that clear it's it's it's
hard to know
what to what to believe and people are
going to choose what they want to
believe
i do not like drawing conclusions or
making leaps
what do we know right now a guy dress a
a
a a lawyer supporting men for
seemingly no reason no relation to the
story i don't know her care
disguised himself went to a judge's
house killed her son injured her husband
that's about it now the latest update we
have
uh something that's this is from abc
news breaking suspect and shooting of
judge's family found dead of apparently
self-inflicted gunshot wound
multiple law enforcement sources tell
abc news the deceased suspect was an
attorney
who had a case before judge salus in
2015.
so i don't know what's the likelihood
that somebody who had a grudge
for five years decided to show up and
kill her son
four days after she took this case but
that's another issue too man
it was four days later but is that
enough time to coerce somebody
like she gets assigned to this and then
they call her immediately like you
better do what we want otherwise
tomorrow we're calling you
and then the next day they did it and
then the next day well do you think that
i'm gonna just choose everything wisely
here uh yeah we'll be very careful on
our
choice of words i mean so so you said
like is that enough time for someone to
be coerced
what if that wasn't the the idea what if
they didn't even contact her
if if this is what is happening what if
that's not what the point is
yeah that's what it could be it could be
anybody who gets involved will suffer
yeah and then everyone's gonna say no
way no i'm not touching that oh you took
that case
okay this is what happens not even that
it was assigned to her right that's
that's how it was assigned to is that
that's how it works
i i don't know i don't know how it works
i'm not a lawyer or a judge so i'm i'm
assuming
there's some degree of choice i don't
know but i
but perhaps you know they said hey
here's the case and she received it says
okay
dude shows up four days later i have to
imagine
anybody now who sees this case is going
to be like nope
i'm not touching it that's why i want to
talk about michael hastings too after
this
because you know i've had a lot of
people over the past years tell me
that when you enter the political fray
and start talking about
you know politicians support for
opposition to you become you become
targeted
in in in varying degrees of severity so
like
if you know what i do i'm basically like
well you know the democrats kind of suck
that's not that's that's not the most
egregious thing but the level of
influence the amount of views i get
is an issue so what happens is you get
smeared they try to discredit you
when you become an actual political
operative and are actually doing
bigger high profile things the smears
are substantially worse yeah
when you start doing crazy stuff that
actually gets people elected
all of a sudden then you get criminal
probes you get you know serious criminal
investigations there's a couple
organizations i'm not going to name that
you know
in recent history and then you it come
you come to this
criminal enforcement and judging
overseeing very serious cases
now people are going to send a message
man you know it's one thing to be like
hey democrats are bad it's another thing
to be like i would like to issue a
ruling of discovery in this jeffrey
epstein banking case
so we can see everybody who was involved
in these financial transactions
and have some high ranking officials
from deutsche bank sit in that chair and
tell me everybody who
transferred money and why hmm then all
of a sudden the judge overseeing the
case has a dead son
yep then the guy is found in upstate new
york apparently
of a self-inflicted gunshot wound i
didn't even hear about that until i came
down and you're like
so this is what we're gonna talk about
i'm like okay and then you're then you
drop that and i was like
what like you know you can't write this
no i'll tell you what man more perfect
for like a conspiracy
look what the fbi said the fbi newark
said the fbi has identified roy den
hollander as the primary subject in the
attack that occurred
at the home of the honorable esther
celis den hollander is now deceased
individuals who believe they have
relevant information should contact us
they list their phone number so the fbi
is
is openly reaching out and investigating
this
deceased they didn't say apparent you
know suicide or whatever
well but the new but abc news is saying
that
so it could just be i i think the fbi
wouldn't get into that much detail so
it's probably
a suicide yeah uh yeah man
so uh what are people gonna think
they're gonna think exactly that i
there's something that i know i can't
say that i want to say right now but
i don't i just don't i don't know i
i this is a very touchy subject you know
it's like i have a feeling nobody
out there believes that he did that to
himself i guess that's the
best way to do it somebody tweeted the
man who killed
the epstein judge's son didn't kill
himself
someone else said that right someone
tweeted that right yeah just for context
and they were like is this too so i
think it might have been zero head or
something is this too soon
so here's what i find very very
interesting about this whole thing
when epstein got arrested everybody was
tweeting
okay so we know what happens next right
yeah
and we did it and then we did yeah and
then it happened and everyone
laughed because it was so obvious
yeah well how about we just check that
camera footage to see what happened oh
what's that
the camera was broken so weird well why
don't we ask the the guards what what
oh they were sleeping is that what turns
out it was
yeah i think that's what it was right
there that was what it was yeah they
took naps yeah weird right they were
sleeping
so strange so uh when
whatever what gizzalane every pronounced
her name whatever maxwell gets arrested
then uh a lot of people are saying my
mic is really low
you're i can't do anything about it
you're you're normal
all right seems yeah i don't know why
just just pull that sucker a little bit
closer to your face right there
can't get any it's like your nose can't
do it any closer
but uh i'll try to to speak a little uh
louder into the microphone oh that's
nice that's good is that better
i i just made my voice deeper oh that's
i can hear myself a little clearer
actually
okay cool hopefully that worked sorry to
uh
steer sideways i don't i don't know what
they're doing with
uh gizlane or whatever her name is right
yeah uh they're saying next year is
going to be her her case
yeah a year yeah a year how is that
legal though
what do you mean that's just how they
how they've done it no bail
their their their their charges oh i
don't know dude
yeah so she's actually being tried by
the public corruption
unit okay and a lot of people
immediately pointed out that's weird
yeah that's not supposed to be the the
division that handles this kind of stuff
oh i can't read these on
on live stream it's just trafficking
yeah basically
so so most most of us understand you
know
what yeah trafficking is yep of people
who are not adults
no put it that way yeah jade i don't
think it matters we're going to be
monetized hard on this one whatevs
but uh listen
the people that were involved in this
are very powerful clearly
and they've they've been getting away
with whatever it is for a long time we
don't know who they are i'm not going to
pretend to know who they are
the accusations have been laid out i
believe even ellen powe
the you know feminist former ceo of
reddit said
that in 2011 they all knew they knew
what she was doing
they knew what she was involved in if
that's true
what does that mean for all of the
people who were involved with maxwell
and epstein up until epstein got
arrested
they knew they didn't care well that's
what virginia was saying i don't know if
you remember virginia
but they were she's saying that if um if
sorry there's a bug
she's saying that if um miss maxwell
gets up in front of everybody she could
name some really really significant
names that would change everything
so i'm really curious what happens now
i think uh i have some speculation as to
what's going to happen
what say you good sir oh
man i think i think miss max was in
danger i think most people agree
and i think when it came to you know
epstein everybody
said it and it was a joke and then it
happened and
and then no one believes that what what
they're telling us
and then i actually saw an interesting
tweet i don't remember who who sent it
out there they were saying
if if if he if he did do it to himself
i'm going to be careful with my words if
he did do that
and that's what the story is why would
they be
treating gizlane like she's
in danger yeah so somebody keeps her
around
yeah but but are they can you can you
look that up are they moving around they
are yeah
and uh she said that she's concerned
about her own safety i believe and
didn't she say that
she doesn't believe that epstein no no
she doesn't believe that he um
uh passed away of natural causes oh man
i'm just waiting for someone to kick the
door in and then
you know tim casserole is over that'll
be a good show makes everybody a little
paranoid man
i'll tell you what i'll tell you what
when certainly does you know just
because they're
just because you're paranoid doesn't
mean they're not after you
i think they're desperate whoever
they is i don't know i don't know but
clearly there is a criminal conspiracy
that's why the investigation at deutsche
bank
that's why the criminal charges of
course there are co-conspirators
i'm not playing in any of these
conspiracy tropes i don't care about any
speculation as to who people might think
these people
are no we have arrested the united
states arrested maxwell
she's been charged with certain things
if that's the case there are likely
other people that she's done business
with that don't want their name attached
to it
and so this is what i'm saying man a lot
of people are like
it would be too risky to pull these
things off with a judge like no it must
have been some disgruntled you know
attorney who she ruled against because
it would be too risky
it's not too risky not at all because
now now that she's been targeted
and and likely it's a chilling effect a
lot of people are going to avoid this
case
we're not going to hear the names of
people involved because
who's going to want to go i mean will
they actually in good faith
to the extent that they can actually go
after this properly
or are they going to be like um
everything looks in order here uh okay
dismiss have a nice day
i don't want to be involved if it comes
to maxwell
and her testimony she needs say one name
and people's and whoever whoever's name
that is it's going to be a domino effect
that's a good point
because then they go arrest that person
they bring in people you know what i
mean
so think about it you're this ultra rich
you know multi-millionaire dude
and you know that maxwell
can say your name it may cause riots
it may destabilize everything but why
would you let her testify
you're right they're moving her around
and that's i mean it's
everybody's thinking it everyone's
thinking it you guys are all out there
i'm reading the chat everybody's
you just said it everyone was thinking
it before he
you know whatever happened in his cell
happened
you know the worst part of this is what
it kind of makes me feel like we're in
uh some kind of like
movie but we're all ancillary characters
yeah yeah otherwise you'd know what's
going on
we're we're all side characters we uh
unfortunately
not involved in the main plot yeah yeah
we're just we're just like in
i mentioned this before like we're in
fallout 3 and we're just the wasteland
radio
like playing in the background someone
someone's off doing the adventure
tracking the stuff the actual
investigators but wasn't there um
something to do with the the head lawyer
or judge in new york state that
was replaced the southern district of
new york's um was the name bremer
i do not know it was right before she
got arrested
and then this guy was fired right oh
yeah bill barr tried removing him
and said he was resigning and the guy
said no i'm not and then barr said
you're out get out yeah whoa okay and
then the left
said that this was bilbar trying to
cover things up because this dude who
got removed was
on the level and going after trump when
the right says that this guy was
shielding them and
epstein died while he was the prosecutor
right
i'm sorry man i'm gonna have to side
with that on on the right with this one
in the sense that
whoever worst thing he did was arrest
gizlane no no whoever's involved in
epstein
you got to get rid of them right because
at the very
you know worst case scenario is
this guy died on the watch of all of
these people good point
no sorry you know they you gotta you
gotta get some new people
in there even if it's an issue of
incompetence yeah and this guy was like
no
he wasn't he was like i'm not getting
out so they got rid of him yeah now
maxwell's being rotated so the question
is
if epstein you know
ended himself then why would they be
moving maxwell around and keeping under
super high security
right well it literally says in this
article i found that they're worried
about assassination attempts on her
that's what they say i mean i'm reading
them the new york post so i'm gonna go
with that
so so let me let me ask you then the new
york post that they're worried about
assassination attempts yep
they're worried about assassination
attempts and an assassin just showed up
and killed the son of a judge
that was overseeing a lawsuit for
epstein's finances right
look man let me let me live with all you
guys not only that hold on not only that
it was they they continued
working with him after he got in trouble
and that's that's what they're they're
being investigated by because they
continued
to work with him even though they he was
being prosecuted
for what he was doing interesting in
2008 i believe
when it was when he found out or when he
was found out right
and then they continued just working
with them and then that was that's why
they
they're being investigated now i just
want to make sure everyone understands
there we are we are on the razor's edge
with this live show right now that is
correct
and you say one wrong word and they're
just sitting there waiting their fingers
shaking like say it
i'm gonna ban you and he didn't say it
just say the one wrong word and we're
gonna smash that band button no
no yeah so we gotta be really really
careful about yeah you know
but i'll be honest with you guys i'm not
a big fan of conspiracy theories in any
capacity
because people like to make assumptions
and then when you do it actually makes
it harder to figure out and you also
have to be
be careful because when there are actual
conspiracies they're going to throw you
red herrings on purpose
so that you say something dumb and then
as soon as you do
you're off the trail well gotcha and
exactly you're veering towards something
that they wanted you to go towards
right that's what you're digging into
when they're over there when wikileaks
released a bunch of emails
we saw really strange conversations from
high profile figures
all of a sudden these fake posts popped
up lying
just literally making up slang terms
they were like this word means this and
this word means that literally made it
up
everyone just bought it and it became
the narrative
to where they're like look for this word
and that word and it's just nonsense
yeah they threw everyone off the actual
trail
and it was brilliantly done i remember
because i remember when
these like conspiracies were emerging
and i was following the emails because
it was a wiki
wikileaks release i was looking at what
was being said about this very
interesting stuff here's some leads and
then all of a sudden for some reason
a bunch of fake posts popped up and
started getting spread
and now everyone believes it's still to
this day people believe fake things
i see it all the time completely fake i
see it all the time
but some of it is real the problem is it
took only one person probably some it
could be it could look
it could range from some dumb person in
their basement laughing being like i'm
gonna make this up and press enter
to an intelligence you know agency or a
state you know funded agency being like
let's throw them off our trail
and that's why conspiracy theories are a
problem if you don't have evidence
stop yep so now we have stupid
conspiracy theories
which make it impossible to actually
track down who did what because the
whole thing's discredited
now you can't even talk about it that's
all it's it's it's it's so annoying
you know what man i mentioned earlier
that the one of the reasons why there's
no real journalist is because of the the
you know threat to people's safety and
stuff like that yeah but the other
reason is just
people well for one money easier to make
money doing other things
but when someone throws
false evidence and an internet community
just gobbles it up like red meat
yeah it creates this this bubbles echo
chamber that's not journalism that's
true and so
opportunists will chase after it to make
money they'll jump in the pit with
everybody else
and then once everyone's in the pit
youtube goes snip chops it off and
throws everyone in the band list
you can actually do real journalism
tracking this stuff so i'll just say man
you know
there are a lot of emails that got
leaked a lot of really weird stuff
that may suggest weird things yeah and
then fake
news jumped in and now the whole thing
is a muddy mess of fake news i can't you
can't actually
break through well i know that there's
um
there's all these statistics going
around about how many
traffickers are being arrested
under trump the trump administration
yeah comparing it to the obama numbers
is that is that true though i mean i've
seen screenshots of it yeah
well that's kind of what i was i was
going to talk about and i i have
something pulled up here and it's just
he this is this is a quote from him he's
saying my
my administration is putting
unprecedented pressure on traffickers
home and abroad he said during an event
he said we have signed more legislation
on human trafficking than any other
administration has ever
even thought about it of course it's a
little but he
authorized over 400 million dollars in
in fighting the issue so he he's pushing
he's pushing for it you know and a lot
of people
i i ask you know i asked a tweet a
couple weeks ago like what what is it
about
trump that you really like and a lot of
people said that that's the number one
thing
that he's fighting trafficking there's
this uh young woman who's going viral
because apparently she got red pilled on
trump yeah traffickers right
jude i don't know i don't care to you
know i'm not saying this
i'm just pointing out that a lot of
people quickly jumped on it
she put a tick tock and she was saying
like once you realize trump is actually
going after the traffickers like you
kind of wake up to it yeah
i do think a lot of people are wrapped
up in
too much conspiracy theory i can agree
with that we know we so i i think it's
fair to say
for an average person tracking what the
justice department has done with epstein
his history the witnesses who have come
out this dude was
trafficking and so is you know gizlane
or whatever
maxwell and they're being arrested and
charged for these things because there's
probable cause there's grand there's
evidence
they're going after him from there we
can speculate as to all the people who
flew on his plane
who've been on his island and i believe
that does include donald trump
there's a lot of photos of him with
epstein and you know a lot of other
people
which leads the left to argue trump is
trying to cover up and the right saying
he's trying to go after the guy
i think there was some lawyer who said
that
donald trump was the only person who
actually said my resources at your
disposal did you see that
yeah to take him out right exactly to go
he told the lawyer who was
defending one of the victims yeah trump
was like let me know what you need
exactly yeah
so in my personal opinion having seen a
lot of these stories
you know what's going on i personally
think that trump is more likely
to be going after these people and
trying to get them i absolutely think
that
yeah definitely from from i mean i've
done
extensive research on donald trump over
the past month
and all all of the things that i've seen
has
has shown me that he is absolutely
against this and wants
wants to bring them down so we'll see
you know if something happens you know
there someone tweeted this when epstein
got arrested they said
if epstein gets arrested we riot right
i'm sorry i'm sorry if he kills himself
we right not if he gets arrested
and then with maxwell they said the same
thing and i'm just like yeah
you didn't write before they're not
going to right now isn't it crazy what
people riot for
like you have you have epstein and
maxwell you know what they're doing it's
like
what's going on man well it'd be
interesting to to see
what would happen if mainstream media
pushed the narrative
like they do other things i don't want
to
specifically call anything out but they
make it
they do you know play with people's
emotions
and if they were to didn't a bunch of do
it this way
you know what would it would they riot
would they i don't know
didn't a bunch of people in media fly
with epstein go to his diddler island
probably why they're not talking about
it yeah man
man we live in a creepy country with a
bunch of creepy people doing creepy
stuff man
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next
episode
you